bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après midi
en direct sur notre antenne
l'audition de nicole bricq la ministre
du commerce extérieur
elle est entendue par la commission des
affaires économiques et par la
commission des affaires européennes du
sénat
cette audition intervient alors que le
déficit commercial de la france a
légèrement a diminué en avril dernier il
atteint 4,51 milliards d'euros contre
4,69 milliards d'euros en mars dernier
il faut dire que ces derniers temps les
ventes de matériel informatique ou
encore electronic ont augmenté mais a
également à la france a connu un
redémarrage en matière d'exportation ce
qui concerne les transports avec la
vente d'un paquebot de deux satellites
ou encore d'importantes livraisons
d'airbus ou d'avions d'affaires alors
sans plus tarder la direction la salle
clémenceau poursuivra cette audition bon
après midi à tous la ministre sommes
très heureux de vous retrouver sur les
lieux de vos crimes précédents prix
ayant tous les cas 12 et cueillir
conjointement la commission des affaires
européennes dans cette maison qui ne
demandera qu'à vous voir revenir à la
fin de votre mandat
si tant est qu'il en ait qui est une fin
rien jour ou l'autre
tous les cas vous savez très bien amitié
tous les cas le respect que j'ai eue
pour votre travail à la commission des
finances
je vous rappelle tout d'abord que le 5
juin dernier nous avons adopté la
proposition de résolution européenne
portant sur un partenariat
transatlantique
certains où d'aucuns comme on dit ont pu
faire observer que nous avons travaillé
dans des conditions acrobatiques mais là
sportif que vous êtes ça devrait pas
vous déplaire
les l'enjeu le justifiée puisque l'union
européenne et les etats unis d'amérique
représentent ensemble près de la moitié
du pib mondial
il ya un tiers des échanges mondiaux nos
deux commissions ainsi tout mis en
oeuvre pour que le sénat puisse
renforcer le poids du gouvernement
français lors du prochain conseil de
l'union européenne consacré à ce sujet
et en particulier dans le cadrage de moi
j'appelle ça la lettre de mission de la
commission
simultanément il semblerait que nos
relations avec la zone asie-pacifique
prennent un nouveau visage vous pourrez
peut-être nous en dire plus sur le
partenariat d'exception avec le japon
suite à la visite du des places suite à
la visite du président de la république
et je j'ai vu à la télé que vous
l'accompagnez à dire non
non c'était oui nommé parce qu'on est
oui parce qu'on a
c'était geneviève à part dans fioraso
qui est des oiseaux enfin deux
rapporteurs et l'ensemble des
commissaires ne manquerons pas de vous
poser diverses questions y compris
peut-être en abordant la question
particulière sensible des chevauchements
de compétences entre les divers
ministères et dennis des initiatives
lancées ici ou là qui témoigne à tout le
moins d'une volonté partagée de relever
le défi de la compétitivité de
l'offensive à l'exportation je vais tout
de suite passé la parole à notre
collègue bernadette bourzai qui remplace
avantageusement notre collègue simon 6
tours qui est retenu par un voyage je ne
sais où mais en tous les cas qui a donné
mandat à bernadette pour s'exprimer au
titre de la commission des affaires
européennes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
chers collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
excusé le président simon sutour qui se
trouve actuellement en déplacement à
l'étranger et qui avait prévu je crois
que vous recevoir le 4 juin à madame la
ministre mais son agenda ne
correspondait plus je souhaiterais
ensuite remercié madame la ministre
d'avoir permis que cette réunion se
tienne en temps opportun quelques jours
avant la réunion du conseil européen qui
doit se prononcer sur le mandat de
négociation du partenariat
transatlantique
la perspective de cette négociation à
inquiéter tous ceux qui sont attachés à
la spécificité européenne et en
particulier à la spécificité française
en matière de politique culturelle
concernant les services audiovisuels
préserver la diversité culturelle est en
effet un objectif permanent mais il est
spécialement nécessaire de le mettre en
avant
quand il s'agit des relations avec les
états unis compte tenu de leur
prépondérance en matière de services
audiovisuels
les premières propositions de résolution
déposée au sénat
l'une par la présidente de la commission
des affaires culturelles marie christine
blandin l'autre par le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen portait
exclusivement sur ce thème
la commission des affaires européennes
qui en étaient six
il a cependant souhaité que le sénat se
prononce sur l'ensemble du mandat de
négociation et pas seulement sur cet
aspect quelle que soit son importance
la commission des affaires économiques
ensuite confirmée et complétée cette
approche nous adhérons tous à l'idée que
les services audiovisuels doivent être
clairement exclu des négociations
en effet il ne s'agit pas seulement pour
nous comme semble le considérer la
commission européenne de pouvoir
conserver les systèmes dead existants il
s'agit pour les européens de pouvoir
définir eux-mêmes leur politique dans un
domaine en pleine évolution
technologique
ce préalable étant posé il n'est pas
souhaitable que la position française
apparaissent uniquement défensive est
négative à supposer que les limites
soient bien fixées dès le départ un
partenariat transatlantique pour
représenter une opportunité majeure
compte tenu du poids cumulé des deux
partenaires un accord pourrait avoir un
effet d'entraînement vers une meilleure
régulation du commerce mondial et nous
avons des objectifs positif à faire
valoir dans cette optique comme la
protection des droits de propriété
intellectuelle et notamment les iger p
la réciprocité dans l'ouverture des
marchés publics ou encore la protection
des données personnelles et la
convergence des règles prudentielles
mais il n'en est pas moins nécessaire
d'être l'une extrême vigilance sur les
aspects qui touchent à nos valeurs
fondamentales pas de nivellement vers le
bas pour les règles sociales et
environnementales respect des
préférences collectives qu'exprime la
législation européenne en matière
d'agriculture et d'alimentation
et bien sûr je n'y reviens pas respect
de l'exception culturelle
dans cette optique madame la ministre
que peut-on attendre de la réunion du
conseil européen du 14 juin
on lit dans la presse spécialisée que la
commission européenne aurait
retravailler son projet de mandat de
négociation
qu'en est il est ce que nos partenaires
européens sont nombreux à partager nos
préoccupations
ou bien y at il des approches très
différentes et donc divergentes au sein
du conseil
il ne serait très utile d'avoir des
précisions sur ses poils pour
est ce que comme parlementaire nous
aurons à faire par la suite
merci madame la ministre de vos réponses
la ministre vous avez le temps oui merci
monsieur le président et madame la
présidente je suis évidemment toujours
très heureuse de revenir au sénat la
présidente bonsaï vous avez indiqué que
nous avions un rendez vous avec la
commission européenne le 4 juin que je
n'ai pas pu honorer pour des questions
d'agenda mais finalement je trouve que
c'est pas plus mal de le faire
aujourd'hui parce que on est vraiment
dans l'actualité puisque vendredi au nom
de la france
je représenterai notre position devant
mes collègues mais valve six autres
collègues ministres du commerce
extérieur et je viens ici vous l'a
précisé
vous avez rappelé tous les deux
l'importance de cette négociation onu
union européenne etats unis 40 % du
commerce mondial
deux tiers des investissements innovants
dans le monde
évidemment ce qui sortira de cette
négociation qui va être longue et
difficile qui peut durer plusieurs
années
la commission a dit un peu aventureux
heureusement que en deux ans ça devait
être bouclée quand je vois qu'avec le
canada l'union européenne est parti la
fleur au fusil
avec un mandat des états membres assez
élastique et je vois que arrivé au bout
de cinq ans nous n'arrivons pas à
conclure parce que tout ce que nous
avions évacué au début revient in fine
est d'autant que et le canada c'est un
état fédéral
les etats-unis sont aussi un état
fédéral et nous savons d'ores et déjà
que très états membres sur 50 ne se
sentent absolument pas ne sont pas
juridiquement engagées par des accords
commerciaux conclus par l'état fédéral
donc et on nous savons aussi j'ai pu
m'en d'assurer quand je suis allé aux
états unis au mois d'avril
j'ai rencontré le négociateur américain
j'ai rencontré les ong américaines les
syndicats américains le congrès le
représentant
très solide des agriculteurs américains
le négociateur américain dans gpa
compris que nous avions affaire à forte
partie
donc ce qui sortira de ces négociations
à l'évidence vont avoir un caractère
normatif pour l'ensemble du commerce
mondial alors je vois bien monsieur le
président vous y avez fait allusion
vous avez parlé de l'accord le type
hippie le trans par serre
pacific partnership qui les américains
sont en train de négocier avec tous les
pays de la côte pacifique
je vois bien aussi que les etats-unis
visent à faire deux accords majeurs qui
ils auront les grands émergents et
notamment la chine
je parle commerce je parle pas politique
mais si les américains la politique
n'est jamais très loin du commerce et
vice et versa et donc je vois bien 7,7 à
laon maintenant quand je suis allé aux
états unis j'ai pas senti vraiment le
congrès est encore loin d'avoir bien
d'être entrées dans dans cette affaire
avec l'union européenne en revanche je
vois bien que ils ont les yeux rivés sur
le pacifique
mais je ne doute pas que la volonté
exprimée par le président obama
rencontre de conclure un accord avec
l'union européenne rencontrera europe
rencontrera un enthousiasme du congrès
qui va beaucoup défendre les intérêts
des états américains mais effectivement
vous l'avez dit madame la présidente
nous avons compte tenu de l'importance
du sujet un intérêt
ok qui est vraiment de commerce mondial
c'est vrai que si on arrive au bout de
cet accord dans de bonnes conditions
ça va faire réfléchir tous les grands
émergents
parce que qui seront pas dans cet accord
si il arrive à bon port
et je vais vous dire les conditions pour
nous français pour nous européens du bon
d'arriver à bon port
c'est évident que des pays comme la
chine comme le brésil pour ne parler
d'eux que deux qui sont dans l' omc vont
paradoxalement vouloir se réfugier sous
la halle du multilatéralisme dont on
sait qu'il est encalminée parce que il
pourrait être exclu de normes du
commerce mondial donc plutôt que de voir
un cheval de troie dans cet accord de
libre échange contre le multilatéralisme
on peut le regarder aussi en dynamics
avec la france est très attachée au
multilatéralisme et aux règles de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
alors quand on regarde objectivement
cette affaire on a un intérêt global moi
j'ai consulté les entreprises françaises
elles sont favorablement
elles sont plutôt favorables il ya une
majorité favorable
il ya tout un secteur qui est assez
divisés c'est le secteur agroalimentaire
où il y a des des intérêts offensifs
comme on dit notamment dans les produits
laitiers dans dans pas mal de deux
produits
d'alimentation et en même temps il ya
des secteurs qui sont plutôt
défavorables
je pense par exemple l'ania est partagé
en deux c'est très simple a pas de
position
j'ai réuni tout ce monde là après la
consultation par internet
ils sont venus à bercy et l'ania manila
représente mme hamdani on est moitié
moitié et c'est vrai que il y aura
certainement un intérêt à demander à une
clause de sauvegarde pour certains
secteurs notamment concernant des normes
de maïs et amis gants donc qui est très
présent dans l'agroalimentaire c'est
vrai qu' il faudrait qu'on obtienne une
clause de sauvegarde comme on l'a
obtenue dans la négociation pour le
japon concernant le secteur automobile
donc mais on a dans l'agroalimentaire
des intérêts offensifs on en a dans la
pharmacie on en a dans la chimie
c'est aussi important on en a dans le
textile et l'habillement notamment en
termes de droits de douane qui sont très
élevés donc on a quand même une série d'
intérêts offensifs et on en a un très
important et je veux remercier le sénat
qui a c'est la commission la commission
européenne vous avez soutenu là
la venue devant le parlement européen du
règlement sur les marchés publics
c'est là où je veux en venir je trouve
dommage que malgré deux sommet européen
qui ont rappelé des chefs d'état qui ont
rappelé la volonté exprimé formellement
que le règlement concernant les marques
l'ouverture des marchés publics dans les
pays tiers
vienne devant le parlement européen eh
bien nous avons un blocage persistant de
l'allemagne qui est défavorable
la réciprocité n'est pas une notion
admise par nos partenaires
il y voit un réflexe protectionniste ils
ont tort parce que engager une
négociation avec les états unis ça
aurait été mieux si nous avions ce
règlement d'ouverture des marchés
publics ils ont eu tort c'est un aveu de
faiblesse
mais le blocage allemand n'a pas pu être
levée malgré la volonté du président
hollande qu'il avait fait inscrire dans
deux déclaration finale du sommet de
semer européen c'est dommage je pense
que c'est pas bon pour aborder une
négociation telles que celles que nous
allons avoir avec les états unis mais
donc je sais que vous avez soutenu cette
cette volonté l'assemblée en a fait de
même et demain du reste je serai en
séance à l'assemblée nationale puisque
une proposition de résolution va être
déposé a été déposée débattu en
commission et vient devant devant la
d'un an dans l'hémicycle sur un autre
sujet que je réserve pour la faim
concernant les services audiovisuels et
l'exception culturelle donc des intérêts
offensifs des intérêts aussi défensif
vous savez que nous défendons est là la
commission a bien avancé dé les
indications géographiques
nous y sommes très attachés nous sommes
pas les seuls en europe nous voulons
ça c'est un différend avec les états
unis qui ont et défendre des marques
nous on défend des indications
géographiques
mais on n'est pas seuls beaucoup de pays
en ont eux mêmes vous savez j'étais en
malaisie la semaine dernière et en
indonésie
il adopte des indications géographiques
aussi pour défendre leur riz enfin bon
je fais pas des tours mais ça devient
quand même bien c'est l'europe qui a
quand même inventé ça la france
donc il faut en obtenir le plus possible
avec les états unis mais je crois que là
la commission a bien avancé à la volonté
et il y à aussi
un sujet important nous avions demandé
nous la france que les marchés de
défense
toutes les industries de défense soient
exclus de la négociation
nous avons été soutenus très vite par
tous ceux qui ont une industrie de
défense
l'angleterre et les suédois qui ont
aussi une industrie de défense notamment
dans l'aérien
donc la commission a accepté qu'on ne
met pas dans le mandat
la défense nous avons un autre sujet
important où nous avons demandé avec
l'allemagne notamment que
le mécanisme qui étaient inclus au
départ de règlement des différends et à
investisseurs soit pour le moins
beaucoup mieux encadrer j'explique ce
que c'est parce que c'est la première
fois que nous allons nous engager dans
une négociation où nous allons mettre
aux côtés des relations commerciales
tout ce qui concerne l'investissement et
nous avons déjà des mécanismes qui
d'état à état prévoit des mécanismes de
règlement des différends des contentieux
et nous sommes notre position à nous
français mais l'allemagne est sur cette
position aussi et de dire ces mécanismes
d'état à état suffisent pour quoi quand
on regarde l'application de l'alena qui
est l'accord qu'a conclu qu ont conclu
les états unis d'amérique avec le
mexique notamment on voit que cette ce
mode de règlement investisseurs et à a
été introduit dans l'accord de libre
échange et on voit compte tenu de la
puissance des lobbies américains
on voit que cette année un contentieux
ça veut dire que les états le mexique en
l'occurrence est régulièrement attaquée
par des entreprises américaines pour non
respect de l'accord donc ça ne voulons
pas que nos entreprises soient tout le
temps soumise au feu roulant des
lobbyistes américains
il ya des accords d'état et à ça suffit
alors la commission a fait un pas en
avant elle a accepté alors les allemands
ne demandez pas l'exclusion parce que ça
vous je vous en dise hameau de la
tactique mais les allemands étaient très
attachés
ce que on encadre bien
ce mécanisme donc il reste dans la
négociation mais il est encadré comme le
souhaitait les allemands comme nous le
souhaitions
pour éviter les dérives alors après
c'est l'objet de la négociation parce
que les américains vont pousser leur
avantage c'est normal dans une
négociation en avance ou on recule
et puis quelques fois on trouve des
compromis au milieu mais c'est très
important je voulais vous le signalez
donc la commission à avancer sur
certains sujets alors évidemment il ya
le gros sujet des préférences
collectives
vous savez ce que c'est les préférences
collectives c'est nos législations
européennes et nationales
bon nous en avons en matière agricole
très importante
nous ne voulons pas d'objets m ça c'est
une position commune à tous les états
membres
donc là je pense que c'est très clair
alors évidemment en contrepartie on l'a
bien vu aux états unis avec leurs
représentants du monde agricole
on a bien vu que le problème des quotas
d'exportation de viande de boeuf non aux
hormones
en contrepartie ils vont nous dire mais
on va vous allez augmenter un peu mais
ça fait partie de la négociation
maintenant aux autres pontes deux ogm
non boeuf aux hormones je les dis et
nous avons aussi le sujet de la viande
delà de la méthode de décontamination
des carcasses ont ça on n'en veut pas
fait pas comme ça donc ils le savent
alors je crois que là il y aura pas d
parler des indications géographiques
je pense que là il y aura pas deux il
n'y a pas de sujet de discorde entre les
européens on est tous d'accord et les
américains l'ont compris alors je
voulais vous dire aussi un mot de bien
sûr des services audiovisuels
alors en la matière la france défend une
position très ferme instruit de ce qui
s'est passé pour le canada où nous
n'avons voulu mettre aucune exclusion et
cinq ans après on revient au point de
départ
donc nous disons à la commission que
nous n'en voulons pas nous n'avons
jamais mis dans un accord commercial
les services culturels et audiovisuelle
jamais jamais jamais il ya eu des
velléités notamment 1994 le commissaire
européen c'était monsieur leur britten
et au moment de la conclusion de
l'accord d'huguette du gatt avant
d'arriver avant le fbi et il ya eu une
velléité de remettre ce sujet à l'époque
c'était le président mitterrand et le
président clinton qui ont dit non on ne
met pas et depuis on n'a jamais mis dans
une négociation commerciale et je
voulais dire au passage à madame la
présidente que ce qui concerne les
données personnelles
ça ne relève pas d'un accord de libre
échange ça c'est très clair et le
commissaire de buch qui le commissaire
européen l'a dit dans toutes les
réunions techniques alors évidemment les
américains vont vouloir mai
nous veillerons aussi dans le suivi à ce
que ça ne revienne pas sur la table
donc l'exception culturelle c'est pas le
combat des gaulois tout seul on n'est
pas isolés parce que moi j'ai quand même
beaucoup consulté encore la semaine
dernière où il ya quinze jours quand il
ya eu la réunion de l' ocde à paris j'ai
eu beaucoup de bilatérales
donc beaucoup de pays disent on est
d'accord avec vous mais on ne veut pas
que ce soit exclue parce que si c'est
exclu les américains vont nous devons
nous vendre vont eux-mêmes exclure oui
mais moi je sais je suis allé aux états
unis je sais c'est ce que je dis à mes
collègues et ce que je dis à au
commissaire mais de toute façon ils vont
demander d exclusion vous savez que dans
la négociation il ya aussi tout ce qui
concerne les services financiers et la
finance et les assurances où nous avons
des intérêts offensifs parce que un
assureur européen ne peut pas agir aux
etats-unis le marché est fermé nous
allons la finance pure et puis nous
avons là les services bancaires et j'ai
posé la question aux négociateurs
américains quand je suis allé je lui ai
dit mais comment allez-vous faire parce
que vous avez nombreuses agences
indépendantes
j'ai posé la même question sur les états
qui ne sont pas liés par un accord
commercial les 13es il manie vous poser
la bonne question que j'ai pas la
réponse parce que et notamment je sais
que dans les services bancaires
assurantiel et financier ils vont
demander l'exclusion donc autant s'y
préparer en ayant nos lignes rouges et
ce faisant je défends non seulement
des des législations nationales mais
aussi la diversité culturelle européenne
c'est clair alors ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que si je mène un raisonnement
au bout vous nous avons des politiques
de subvention du cinéma de l'industrie
audiovisuelle non seulement je vais
défendre l'industrie audiovisuelle
mais en même temps je dis on ne sait
jamais vous avez vu l'évolution des
technologies en matière de communication
à ce qu'il ya 15 ans on aurait pu penser
qu' il y avait une telle diversité de
moyens audiovisuels qu'est-ce qu'on sera
dans dix ans au moment où pourrait
s'appliquer l'accord
je ne le sais pas donc moi je protège ce
qui ce qui est aujourd'hui identifiées
mais demain donc je ne veux pas que ce
soit dans la négociation alors
évidemment mes collègues disent oui oui
mais c'est vrai vous avez raison alors
on a un peu l'impression que la france
tout le monde est d'accord avec elle
mais quand il s'agit d'aller au bout au
bout c'est quoi c'est de dire si la
commission persiste en plus je trouve
que c'est pas très adroit politiquement
dans une période où on voit bien que
l'europe suscite de plus en plus de
désamour c'est pas très malin avant des
élections européennes de persister sur
ce qui n'est pas qu'emblématique qui est
aussi le fait que on veut garder nos
législations nationales et européennes
en la matière
certes on veut protéger notre industrie
puis les américains ne le demande pas
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire j'ai
même vu dès lors du festival de cannes
des grands producteurs
les etats-unis qui sont venus dire aux
cinéastes européens réunis à cannes
qu'il était d'accord donc qui tenait à
cette diversité mais comme nous et dont
beaucoup le cinéma et la culture vous
avez voté vous sénat la tva réduite pour
le livre numérique
vous avez bon on a pris des positions en
soutien le cnc bon et qui me peux me
dire que demain les représentants de
l'état fédéral américain dire on médite
dont les conditions je n'y a pas de
réciprocité
vous vous aider nous pas ça ne va pas il
pourrait nous attaquer devant l'om s'est
donc si des ouvriers c'est très concret
et en même temps on peut me dire ah bah
oui mais la france comme d'habitude elle
n'est pas d'accord mais vous avez vu un
soutien formel des états membres quand
la france a décidé d'intervenir au mali
on était tout seul dans la fée pour
l'europe on l'a fait pour le monde
eh bien c'est la portée d'un message
universel de la france et je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on soit si isolé que ça en tout
cas
est ce que la commission prendra le
risque que la france deuxième puissance
économique européenne ne donne pas de
mandat il ya quand même un petit
problème pour une négociation aussi
importante suis pas sûr qu'elle puisse
se passer de l'accord de la france
et si elle décidé de s'en affranchir
je pense que le sujet devient politique
au niveau des chefs d'état y un sommet
européen je dis ça parce qu'il ya un g20
qui a lieu à londres et que le président
obama va venir à berlin
et je pense qu'il s'exprimera sur cet
accord de libre échange
il est à berlin je crois que c'est le 18
ou 19 pour le 50e anniversaire de la
déclaration de du président kennedy
ich bin ein berne hilaire pour ceux qui
s'en souviennent et je crois que vous
êtes nombreux ici à vous en souvenir
voilà donc voilà où on en est
moi je veux bien rendre compte après
donc pour faire la part de choses des
intérêts offensifs une négociation qui
va être longue et difficile d intérêt
défensif aussi d une ligne rouge
des avancées qui sont insuffisantes à
l'heure actuelle et je pense que nos
collègues croient sincèrement je vois
bien que ma collègue hollandaise dit
mais on peut obtenir l'ouverture des
ports américain au commerce e au fret
européen ils ont des intérêts offensifs
bien sûr avec un grand port comme
rotterdam
mais je pense que là c'est quand même
faire preuve d'une certaine naïveté est
en tout cas ce que je ne veux pas c'est
que la culture fasse l'objet d'un
chantage à la négociation c'est trop
facile de nos corner risée de dire oh
bah si vous voulez obtenir deux
indications géographiques de plus vous
enlevez vous avez vous en leveaux
négocier ça en contrepartie de la
culture je ne marche pas je ne marche
pas dans le ce n'est pas un objet de
marchandages voilà alors je vais vous
dire un mot aussi en matière de
politique commerciale de la chine
rapidement ça c'est important parce que
vous avez remarqué que dans la dernier
parcours la commission fait valoir des
intérêts de défense commerciale la
france a toujours été favorable aux
intérêts de défense aux mesures de
défense commerciale
c'est la compétence de la commission
c'est très important de le rappeler la
compétence exclusive de par les traités
donc comment fait la commission en
matière de panneaux photovoltaïques elle
a été saisie par essentiellement par un
consortium allemand et un consortium
français aussi mais consortium allemand
et les intérêts allemands sont très
supérieurs aux nôtres même si ça nous a
mis en difficulté et à un photowatt
c'est dans la tête de tout le monde mais
surtout elle a fait son travail elle a
été saisie
elle a fait son travail technique et
elle a conclu au printemps dernier elle
a conclu au fait qu' il y avait
effectivement une procédure anti dumping
a proposé aux états membres
donc elle nous l'a proposé et nous avait
déjà sondé à dublin lors du sommet
informel et elle n'a finalement proposé
d'engager une procédure anti dumping à
l'encontre des de la chine est là
proposer des mesures provisoires c'est à
dire que pendant un an il y aura un
surcroît de droits de taxes de 11% pour
in fine et être à 40 7% en décembre
c'est assez raisonnable et à côté de ça
c'est passé plus inaperçu mais elle a
engagé aussi une enquête
et là elle a utilisé une procédure
exceptionnelle
c'est à dire qu'elle s'est autosaisie ça
s'appelle la procédure ex officio en bon
matin elle s'est autosaisie sur le
domaine des télécommunications savait
que la chine possède deux grandes
entreprises
oui et zte et elle va enquêter faire le
même travail
elle proposera un moment donné aux états
membres de prendre une position
murray semblablement pour sonder deux
groupes très puissamment aidée par
l'état et il ya une distorsion est
évidente de subventions donc de
pratiques de dumping donc elle nous
demandera aussi notre avis alors ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire que la commission prend
position dans une se met en position de
négocier avec la partie chinoise
notamment durant cette année et il n'y a
pas de guerre commerciale avec la chine
alors pour vous donner une idée les
contentieux parce qu'on sait pas les
seuls contentieux que nous avons avec la
chine depuis qu'elle est rentrée dans
l'om sait il ya quand même des
contentieux mais les contentieux europe
chine
ça représente 1 % du commerce et
personne n'a intérêt à une guerre
commerciale
nous n'avons pas intérêt à une guerre
commerciale nos entreprises supportent
de plus en plus et la chine quand
l'europe est en difficulté on voit bien
qu'on est le premier client des
des chinois n'ont pas intérêt non plus à
cette guerre donc je crois que la
commission a bien fait nous nous lavons
soutenues très fermement pour se mettre
en position de négocier un bon compromis
donc je résume la position pas de guerre
commerciale avec la chine tout ce dont
la chine n'y a pas intérêt non plus mais
être en position de négocier et de
mettre à profit cette année pour le
faire ça c'est qu'il me semble une
posture assez intéressante et la
commission a bien fait et alors
évidemment il ya un effet miroir à ça
l'effet miroir c'est ce qu'a annoncé la
chine à l'endroit de la france le 20 mai
c'est pas nouveau ça ça fait quand même
plusieurs mois que nous savions que il
pourrait y avoir quoi qu'il arrive des
mesures concernant le vin et puis à
l'endroit de l'allemagne les voitures
haut de gamme
donc c'est un aparté ça doit pas être
aux comptes-rendus jeu pas commettre
deux fautes diplomatique c'est pas mon
genre mais bon madame merkel qui n'avait
pas soutenu la commission
bon voilà parce que c'est vrai qu'ils
ont peur des mesures de rétorsion bon
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont pas d'accord
avec l'art est la réciprocité mais il
faut se faire respecter
l'union européenne et 500 millions de
consommateurs c'est la première force de
marché mondial donc c'est pas par hasard
si tout le monde veut faire un accord de
libre échange
donc je pense que ce qui est
ce qui est important de retenir c'est
c'est que bon ça fait partie et de la
négociation
c'est évident que c'est mis sur la table
c'est assez normal il ya des procédures
de contentieux à l'égard d'autres pays
un film états unis bon on pourrait
écrire un roman
donc c'est des relations commerciales
normales mais ce que le message qu'on
veut passer la chine a fait des gros
efforts pour rentrer dans l' omc faut
jamais l'oublier
elle a commencé à vouloir rentrer dans
l'om c'est en 1985 elle y est arrivée en
2001 après beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts
mais il faut qu'elles respectent les
règles du commerce mondial
voilà c'est tout l comme les autres
l'est pas elle n'est pas la seule
donc je pense qu'il faut avoir tout ça
en tête et puis tout s'est terminé sur
un sujet qui est dans les
responsabilités du commerce mondial en
matière de normes sociales et
environnementales
vous avez tous suivi cet accident
tragique qui est intervenu au bangladesh
1167 mort si je fais le décompte exact
des entreprises européennes nord
américaines impliquées dans cette
affaire
indirectement
parce que elles passent elles sont
clientes bon mais il se trouve que après
il ya une chaîne d'intervenants bon
c'est pas toujours facile de les suivre
bon moi je veux insister là dessus parce
que en la matière il y a eu la semaine
il ya quinze jours une réunion de
annuelle de l'osce et des oeufs
je suis intervenu au nom de la france
pour attirer l'attention de l' ocde et
il l'a mis dans ses conclusions sur le
respect quand même de normes
environnementales et sociales
des ong ont pris des initiatives
concernant la sécurité des bâtiments qui
n'est pas respecté à l'évidence au
bangladesh et des entreprises françaises
ont très vite dit comme carrefour ont
très vite dit qu'elle se rallier à cette
charte de sécurité des bâtiments au
chant l'a fait dans la foulée parce que
il se trouve qu'à bercy pourquoi je
m'intéresse à ça parce que je crois à la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale du commerce
et parce que bercy ce n'est pas connu
mais abrite le point global de contact
de l' ocde
nous avons une cellule qui met en oeuvre
ce point de contact quand il ya un
problème c'est un lieu où les ong les
organisations syndicales qui veille au
respect du droit du travail les
entreprises
les élus aussi peuvent se retrouver et
je les ai tous réunis pour que la france
prenne des initiatives je m'en suis
entretenu avec le commissaire européen
monsieur de gauche tu le même au
commerce
il est très sensibilisé l'union
européenne va prendre des initiatives au
mois de juillet concernant le respect de
normes sociales et le commissaire m'a
dit c'est un problème humain aussi
on peut pas faire travailler des gens
comme ça c'est pas possible il pas
question de faire un come on appelle ça
un boycott du bangladesh pas la peine
d'ajouter la misère à la misère mais il
se trouve que le notre ambassadeur
auprès de l'onu pour les droits de
l'homme et français il s'appelle
françois zimeray
il est allé il était au bangladesh juste
après l'accident tragique et il ya vu
des enfants je veux pas faire de pathos
mais des enfants aux membres sectionnés
qui ne pourront plus jamais travaillé de
leur vie et qu'ils étaient dans ce
bâtiment
donc voilà c'est je voulais vous le dire
mais c'est très important
on a une plateforme de la responsabilité
sociale et environnementale au niveau du
premier ministre qui va bientôt du reste
se réunir pas uniquement sur ces sujets
mais il se trouve que je suis une
animatrice il m'a confié ce chantier en
matière commerciale
comme je crois à ma collègue delphine
batho a aussi contribuer ministre de
l'écologie elle contribue aussi sur le
volet environnemental à l'élévation des
normes du commerce mondial j'ai voulu
vous le rappeler parce que c'est pas
uniquement un problème humanitaire
ça attire l'attention je suis pas seul
là-dedans vous savez que là pour
terminer là
là les pays bas sont à la tête des pays
donateurs du bangladesh et ma collègue
des pays-bas vous avez le pays les pays
bas sont très libres échangistes 1 a
pris une initiative jeu de réunir de
tous les états membres dont la france ne
fait pas partie directement un elle
contribué par le biais de la banque
mondiale papa de par le biais de la
viande la banque asiatique mais pas
directement est là elle réunit les pays
donateurs justement pour attirer leur
attention sur le fait qu'il ya un
minimum de règles à respecter
voilà je voulais vous en parler parce
que ça fait partie aussi du commerce
mondial et c'est pour ça que j'ai pris
comme on dit en iep l'oma si le lead de
cette affaire en bon français la tête de
cette initiative et du récit un forum
mondial de l'eau cdo sur ce sujet le 26
juin
on en reparlera bien merci de me nommer
ministres de cette présentation
ce nouveau volet environnementaux et se
fait partie de la proposition de
résolution que nous avons adoptées en
particulier il sur les protections aussi
des données individuelles
je me rappelle de 7 paragraphe bon la
parole est un monsieur roland courteau
oenologue de l'aude dont vous ne serez
pas étonné de mon intervention moi je
voudrais revenir sur la mise en place
des droits antidumping provisoire
2 % par la commission européenne pour
les panneaux photovoltaïques qui
viennent de chine
effectivement comme vous l'avez indiqué
mme la ministre ces droits seront portés
à 47% a compté je crois de mois d'août
2013 c'est ça nous sommes inquiets
je vais vous dire pourquoi je partage
tout à fait là cette position n'est sur
les panneaux photovoltaïques la france a
soutenu cela et elle a eu raison de le
faire c'est très bien mais cependant
nous sommes inquiets je vois que mon
collègue gérard césar ne va pas être
moins que moi car en représailles pékin
lancer une enquête antidumping sur les
vins importés d'europe est dans la phase
iii avec menace de taxation sur les 26
langues et s'est révélée positive
or je rappelle que la chine c'est le
troisième marché pour l'exportation de
vins français
ces 8 5 millions de chiffre d'affaires
et d'importants débouchés
voilà alors bon je sais que vous voulez
de nous rassurer en partie madame la
ministre je sais aussi que où je crois
savoir que le président de la république
l'a appelé à un projet de réunion des 27
et hammam pour dégager je cite une
solidarité de points de vue sur les
négociations avec la chine où un étang
de ce projet madame la ministre monsieur
de montesquiou ou de cette présidence
j'étais un peu surpris et madame le
ministre par votre chiffre sur lequel
les états unis seraient 40% du commerce
mondial parce que parce que tu es un peu
saisis parce que il restait plus
beaucoup de place pour la chine le
brésil la corée
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord il est
évident que la réciprocité est un
élément essentiel
mais quelles sont nos véritables
objectifs dans ce livre échange je peux
très bien comprendre que je lui parle
entre nous sont favorables au
développement du commerce parce que ça
des retombées forcément sur la
production et donc c'est une lutte
contre contre le chômage
mais aujourd'hui l'europe dans sa
moyenne à une faible compétitivité notre
pays en particulier c'était souligné par
le rapport en ocde par le fmi est-ce que
nous avons intérêt à négocier en
position faible
vous avez souligné aussi les problèmes
agricoles
c'est une refusion les ogm mais le
système est un peu boiteux parce que
nous importons du soya ogm du brésil
venezuela et sans doute des états unis
aussi donc les règles sont un peu
confuses et je pense que nous aurions
tout intérêt à ce que ces règles soient
beaucoup plus claire pour le boeuf aux
hormones
vous dites on va peut-être être amenées
en importer un peu plus tpour et non non
il n'ya pas dorman en contrepartie je
sais pas peut-être qu'aujourd'hui c'est
dispensant le quota serait de vous
demander vos sens décidément je
compromets ce que nous venons nous
pollue tout mais parce que c'est un peu
incohérent que refusant le goff le boeuf
aux hormones on augmente un peu la moue
importations non non mais vous avez été
très clair dans ensuite il ya un élément
dont on n'a pas parlé
ce sont les normes comptables qui sont
très différentes et je pense que dans
nos échanges c'est un élément très
important qu'il faut soulever
autre point les subventions et les
conditions financières des exportations
on assisterait périodiquement des
conflits boeing airbus ou boeing et eads
parce qu'ils vont considère que les
l'un subventionné l'autre et nous - ou
et vice versa enfin un problème qui a
été soulevée lorsque vous étiez le
rapporteur de général en commission des
finances la fiscalité des opérateurs
informatiques le cas de google pas
énorme
nous sommes dans une situation de
faiblesse au niveau de l'union
européenne parce que les pays comme
l'irlande et le luxembourg ont des
positions très différentes de la nôtre
est ce que pour négocier d un domaine
qui concerne des milliards d'euros est
ce qu'il n'est pas est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un préalable à ce que les membres de
l'union européenne et de la zone euro en
particulier appliquent les mêmes règles
fiscales à ces opérateurs
merci monsieur martial burqa oui madame
la ministre après la réunion de la
commission européenne et de la
commission économique
vous venez de nous présenter une
position de la france dans ces à
l'europe dans ces négociations qui est
intéressante parce que vous mettez en
avant plusieurs choses dont la clause de
sauvegarde de certains secteurs qui est
pour nous quelque chose de fondamental
deuxième chose les préférences
collectives c'est-à-dire les question
des ogm des hormones
on ne veut pas que l'europe devienne
jardin de monsanto 1 ça serait une
possibilité simplement plusieurs
quelques comment considérations d'ordre
général
cette négociation n'est pas facile et
vous avez dit madame des ministres qu'il
était possible que sur une question
comme celle là il se pouvait que la
france opère un retrait moi j'aime bien
entendre ça parce que on n'a pas affaire
en face de nous à 1-1 politique on à la
première puissance mondiale
on a une puissance qui est régulièrement
mis devant l'om c'est pour des entorses
très sévère à l'om c'est à dire qu'il
veut l'ouverture des marchés mais qui ne
les appliquent pas elle même et surtout
elle a une arme considérable cette
puissance c'est qu'elle manie la
dévaluation de la monnaie qui donne au
niveau de la compétition entre avec la
cheville poldi et qui est une arme
absolue lorsque on parle de
compétitivité et d' équilibre des
échanges et c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié votre intervention
parce que elle est à la fois dynamique
c'est-à-dire une volonté si la
possibilité d'avoir un accord pas à
n'importe quelle condition
parce que une europe ouverte certes mais
une europe verte non et franchement ce
que j'ai entendu dans dans vos propos
tout à l'heure me fait penser que la
france va défendre des positions à
défendre des valeurs dans cet accord
en sachant que
l'entreprise n'est pas facile du tout on
a je le dis bien nous sommes le plus
grand marché au monde
mais à côté de ça la naissance politique
de l'europe reste à faire est en face de
nous on a une à première puissance du
monde qui veut ouvrir bien sûr plus de
marché mais qui en même temps elle n'est
pas prête à regarder les quelques les
quelques plaintes qui à l'om c'est
concernant l'industrie ou
systématiquement lorsque ses dents des
commandes des secteurs sont en danger
elles n'hésitent pas à taxer à mettre
des droits de douane
je prends un exemple que vous avez dit
sur la chine un an avant l'amérique
avait réagi en taxant très sévèrement
les panneaux photovoltaïques
aujourd'hui à mes collègues faisons
attention à l'europe après la porcelaine
elle prend les panneaux photovoltaïques
on sait assez plein que l'europe était
pas soir puis quand elle prend des
bonnes décisions
il faut dire qu'elle va dans le bon sens
j'ai apprécié aussi que la ministre dise
quelle ce qu'on se mettait en position
de négocier pour sortir un moment donné
du blocage et faire en sorte que les
secteurs subventionnés et bien à un
moment donné qui vendent en dessous des
prix de revient soit remis en cause
comme technique de comment de politique
internationale concernant l'exportation
voilà moi je j'ai senti un gouvernement
qui voulait défendre des valeurs des
positions et puis surtout aux cultures
défense service public
ce sont des questions que sur lesquels
on doit être tirée presque intransigeant
un mur puis madame la ministre
à mon tour je voulais revenir sur le
coup de colère de la chine vis-à-vis des
mesures annoncées de la part de la
commission européenne
parce que visiblement ce pays n'a pas
attendu le temps des négociations pour
prendre des mesures de rétorsion
vis-à-vis des produits français et
notamment l'un des plus emblématiques et
donc le vin comme l'a dit notre collègue
roland courteau et toute la filière est
inquiète sachant que c'est une filière
très fortement exportatrice et il y as
je crois mais gérard césar en parlera
peut-être des exemples déjà très
concrets au niveau de cette au niveau de
ce commerce des vins d'exportation
française je voulais aborder un autre
point également avec vous parce que vous
avez l'occasion de vous exprimer sur les
transferts de technologie qui accompagne
un certain nombre d'exportations de
produits et il est même question pour
certains pays émergents de ticket
d'entrée qui qui donc s'attache aux
produits importés la condition serait le
transfert des technologies qui les
accompagnerai alors j'aimerais savoir si
ce point est abordée dans le cadre des
échanges commerciaux ou pas
et quel est votre point de vue sur le
sujet et puis je profite de votre
présence pour vous nous donniez quelques
éléments chiffrés sur notre sur les
chiffres de nos exportations
puisque l'année 2012 bon nous laisse un
sentiment un petit peu mitigé au niveau
des chiffres puisque le déficit est en
léger recul mais plombé par par les
dépenses énergétiques
en revanche sur le premier trimestre
2013 il semblerait qu'il y ait un net
recul des ventes est en tout cas
recule pas vu encore depuis l'année 2009
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
votre analyse sur ce point merci merci
après les codes du rhône après passé par
l'aude le comment je vais donner la
parole au muscadet monsieur vaugrenard
merci mme
le partenariat transatlantique s'il
aboutissait serait effectivement quelque
chose qui ne serait pas anodin vous
l'avez souligné au niveau des échanges
commerciaux bien entendu au niveau du
produit intérieur brut intérieur brut
qui représente l'europe
additionnés aux états unis d'amérique
également au fait que la france
participe à tout cela est quand même la
cinquième puissance économique mondiale
j'ai bien apprécié une particulièrement
une partie de votre intervention lorsque
vous indiquer que nous sommes aussi
porteur d'un message universel et je
pense que les échanges économiques ne
repose pas uniquement sur l'économie il
repose parfois aussi sur les droits
universels et la france est appréciée
aussi pour cela pour son histoire pour
sa culture et on le mesure de manière
souvent très insuffisant lorsqu'on
réfléchit uniquement dans les limites
étroites de notre territoire
ça compte et lorsque vous avez fait
référence en particulier à notre
intervention au mali c'est le type
d'exemple même symbolique qui montre que
cela que cela compte
mais je voulais aller dans cette
direction là précisément lorsqu'on
évoque nos échanges avec la chine vous
avez évoqué le bangladesh tout à l'heure
plus de plus de 1000 morts et notamment
des enfants
on a le sentiment parfois que du fait
qu'un pays a des centaines et de
centaines de millions d'habitants ses
habitants lorsqu'ils meurent ou ses
enfants lorsqu'il décède n'aurait pas la
même valeur qu'à partir du moment ils ne
sont pas dans un pays à la population
moins importante et ceci bien entendu
est parfaitement est parfaitement
scandaleux et anormale et j'en viens
dans cette logique là aux accords qui
existent aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
un certain nombre de pays ont été
acceptés après beaucoup d'efforts vous
l'avez souligné c'était le cas de la
chine de 1985 à 2001
mais au bout du compte sans que seppi
respecte pour autant de manières
rigoureuse les normes de l'organisation
internationale du travail c'est à dire
que ces pays y participent et
bénéficient de leur participation et de
leur adhésion à l'organisation mondiale
du commerce
et pour autant des enfants peuvent
travailler pour élaborer des produits
qui nous sont vendus par ailleurs
l'égalité homme femme n'en parlant pas
dans certains pays même si nous avons
des progrès démarche d'efforts à faire
bref est ce que dans le cas de ce
partenariat transatlantique
il va être discuté également de la
nécessité de faire respecter les normes
de l'organisation internationale du
travail
dès lors que ces billes participent à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
la deuxième question madame les mini
c'est dans l'hypothèse rêvons un instant
où ce par le partenariat transatlantique
était signée assez assez rapidement il
s'imposerait donc dans cette hypothèse à
l'ensemble des 27 pays de l'union
européenne
mais dans cette même hypothèse il ne
s'imposeraient pas à l'ensemble des 50
états des états unis d'amérique est ce
que ceci est logique
est-ce que ce fait même la ne considérez
vous pas que c'est une forme de
concurrence déloyale et que du coup je
dirais presque par un postulat de
réflexion on peut s'interroger sur la
réalité fondamentale de ce partenariat
transatlantique
si je peux sûr que l'amendement
vaugrenard et constitution américaine
puisse passer mais monsieur césar
oui après les autres régions viticoles
sur le bordeaux arrive et le bordeaux a
la preuve que les chinois applique
d'ores et déjà les mesures de rétorsion
je la preuve formelle
vendredi dernier un contenaire de ma
coopérative qui devait partir en chine
n'est pas parti parce que l'importateur
a décidé ne pas le faire partir tant que
le problème n'était pas réglé
donc il ya déjà des mesures coercitives
qui sont prises à vendre les
négociations ça nous paraît important de
le souligner et je crois que c'est pas
fini malheureusement
deuxièmement madame la ministre vous
avez souligné les accords concernant un
lit gp les indications géographiques je
crois que c'est très important
bien fait de souligner par rapport donc
aux accords bilatéraux avec les usa j'en
profite puisque je parle de l'amérique
du nord et aussi de parler du chili le
chili par rapport à la viticulture
madame le ministre
j'attends que les finis mais sa
conseillère
non merci man insiste le chili 1 profite
du fait que la chine prend des mesures
de rétorsion par rapport aux vins
français pour diminuer ses droits de
douane et ainsi envahir il mais ça y est
il est confirme ils ont abaissé leurs
droits de douane pour profiter justement
des marchés à l'exportation par rapport
aux vins chiliens
je voulais le vous le précisez dernier
point que je voudrais souligner c'est il
habite la mûre l'a souligné roland
courteau jaurès il n'y a pas de vous
madame la ministre vous savez à une
éventuelle ubifrance puisque j'ai
l'honneur de représenter le sénat au
conseil notre action d'ubi france nous
sommes rencontrés derrière je vais vous
demander si par rapport au budget 2014
vous soutenez l'action d'ubifrance qui
est quand même le bras séculier de notre
exportations en particulier pour les
petites et moyennes entreprises
merci merci monsieur c'est un an le
bordelais consorts de lait pur qui était
prévu mais monsieur jean bizet merci
monsieur le président quelques quelques
réflexions d'avoir jeu je me réjouis je
pense que comme tous les intervenants
précédents que puisse se lancer un un
contrat de libre échange entre les états
unis et l'union européenne ça va pas
être facile ça durera de nombreuses
années mais il est évident que ça
permettra de recentrer entre guillemets
l'essentiel du commerce mondial qui
était plutôt aux partis en direction du
bloc asie je suis un petit peu je dirais
déçu de l'attitude dans un premier temps
excessivement défensive de l'union
européenne et de la france en
particulier j'ai voté la résolution sur
sur la sur le culturel je vais voter
mais faisons très attention si vous
voulez de ne pas les mélanger est le
contenu et le contenant pour la bonne
raison c'est que vous l'avez fort bien
dit madame la ministre dans 10 ou 15 ans
quand si vous voulez ces mesures
viendront en application quels seront
les contenants de l'époque donc d'emblée
être je dirais assez braquée défensif
sur sur cet aspect je comprends qu'on
puisse être tout à fait prudent ce qui
concerne le contenu
méfions nous donne pas non plus à
nouveau laissé la france à l'écart de
ces grandes évolutions technologiques
je reconnais une honnêteté
intellectuelle
je dirais tardive tardive de l'union
européenne sur le sujet précisément des
hormones parce que on a abandonné
je dirais le champ de la discussion de
ce sujet sur le plan scientifique
puisque connexes qu'alimente codex
alimentarius aidant on n'a jamais pu
arriver à prouver
précisément la dangerosité de cela mais
il faut respecter les préférences jeudi
rennes on appelle collectif donc on
appelle ça maintenant préférences
collectives donc je préfère plutôt
aborder cette approche si vous voulez
sous cet angle là plutôt que sous
l'angle scientifique puisqu'on n'a
jamais prouvé même cas de figure en ce
qui concerne entre guillemets les
biotechnologies je n'aborderai surtout
pas le sujet parce que il y aurait de
quoi faire un un débat à lui tout seul
avec ce avec cette question mais vous
vous le devinez vous le savez maintenant
tout aussi bien que moi c'est un sujet
qui se paiera très cher
je sais à peu près quelle sera la ligne
de partage mais ça se paiera très cher
entre les états unis à l'union
européenne
moi je voudrais revenir sur trois points
si vous voulez en ce qui concerne les
échanges commerciaux internationaux donc
je déborde
je déborde de dudu bilatérales entre les
états unis et est là et l'union
européenne
moi je pense que l'on peut se réjouir de
la désignation de la nomination de
nouveau directeur général à la place de
pascal lamy pascal lamy a été je le dis
très clairement
briand est particulièrement efficace à
la tête de la douane c'est bon au bout
de deux mandats il ne pouvait plus
continuer son successeur monsieur
azevedo que nous avons eu l'occasion
rencontrer dans le cadre de l'ipea
comment dirais je
à bruxelles il ya quelques temps devrait
être en place à partir de septembre
octobre
est ce que ce ne serait pas l'occasion
pour mettre à plat
j'ai déposé trois amendements qui ont
été qui ont été validés il ya à peu près
trois semaines dans le cadre de l'unité
1 de d'accélérer la dématérialisation
union interparlementaire d accélérer la
dématérialisation des procédures
administratives des procédures
administratives des échanges commerciaux
parce qu'on voit très bien que les les
droits de douane si vous voulez sont
arrivés à un point difficilement
compressible davantage 4 5% ce sera
difficile par contre le coût des
procédures administratives procédant à
ces échanges commerciaux sont encore
lourd donc il serait pertinent à mon
avis de dématérialiser ses procédures
je pense que là il y à la france est
fort bien placés pour aborder cette
question et ce sera l'occasion
d'accélérer si vous voulez un
rapprochement nord-sud
là il ya ça a été approuvée si vous
voulez y aillent là il ya une matière à
continuer de travailler ce sujet
deuxièmement cet accord bilatéral entre
les états unis et l'union européenne
devraient se faire mais je pense que ça
se fera mais j'aimerais une confirmation
de votre part devrait se faire sous
l'égide des fondamentaux de l'om sait qu
est par définition multilatérale et donc
il faudrait pas que ces négociations
bilatérales se fasse en marge d'une
approche multilatérale
et le troisième point vous l'avez évoqué
ces les passerelles entre l'oit et et
les instances environnementales
internationales
on la réclame depuis déjà des années
c'est une oeuvre de longue haleine il
faudrait il faudrait maintenant
essayez d'obtenir un résultat est le
dernier point malheureusement je pense
qu'on n'aura jamais d'accord sur ce
point
c'est dommage tout simplement parce que
dans les centres 452 ou 155 pays membres
de l'om c'est beaucoup si vous voulez
sont des pays soit émergents sont en
voie de développement à quand la
redéfinition précisément de cette notion
donc deux pays émergents non mais de
pays en voie de développement parce que
le jour on réglera ce problème
eh bien nous aurons beaucoup moins de
problèmes avec la chine le brésil et
l'inde
merci sigean les paroles et un monsieur
richard llung monsieur le président j'ai
une question simple sur le volet de
propriété industrielle dans ces
négociations ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus est ce qu'il ya un sujet sur
la politique des brevets sur des brevets
américains
je suppose qu'il ya le volet des
indications des différentes indications
géographiques indication d'origine a
rossé et cetera les obtentions végétales
qui est un sujet que nous allons traiter
il ya quelques temps ici voilà est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
sur ce volet là
merci monsieur guerlain le dernier merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
bonsoir j'aurai deux questions qui sont
en marge et en même temps à mon avis au
centre des questions que nous venons
nous poser l'une concerne les études
d'impact régionale c'est à dire au
niveau de la france des grands traités
de libre échange ou accords de libre
échange que nous opérons il ya deux mois
ni j'ai accompagné le premier ministre
dans sa visite officielle au canada au
québec
j'ai cherché pendant plusieurs mois
effectivement obtenir l'impact en france
des études d'impact sur le traité de
libre échange entre le canada et la
france au niveau européen il n'existe
rien au niveau français on m'a pas donné
grand chose j'ai la chance de bien
connaître le gouvernement québécois et
l'assemblée nationale du québec a
procédé pour plus de 7 millions de
dollars d'étude d'impact
donc ils savent très précisément les
scénarii de ce que pourrait donner ces
accords au niveau de la province du
québec et l'autre aspect aussi qui m'a
beaucoup étonné en m'intéressant ces
négociations et notamment rôle joué par
le commissaire au commerce monsieur de
gucht
c'est que il ya eu beaucoup d'étonnement
sur la question effectivement dans les
négociations de l'union européenne avec
le canada du poids d'acceptation ou non
par les différentes provinces des
accords qui est dessiné question qui se
reproduit une puissance pratiquement 10
au niveau des états américains donc
comme la france pente pour le coup
beaucoup plus à bras le corps la
question des négociations entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis
je voudrais savoir alors je sais que le
périmètre de ce qui sera discuté n'est
pas encore déterminée mais si nous
allons véritablement engagé des études
d'impact que cela était d'ailleurs
préconisée par le rapport du président
sur tours et sur lequel nous insistons
beaucoup parce que on entend des juifs
européens on nous dit une augmentation
de 0 5% de la croissance on nous donne
des chiffres d'emploi mais on n'a aucune
idée de ce que ça pourrait donner
concrètement sur l'économie française le
deuxième point bas correspond aussi là
aussi à notre divin autres points
mais qui est aussi lié à mes nombreux
voyages que je fais au canada en inde en
israël jusqu'à hier et où je rencontre
notre diplomatie économique je suis
particulièrement étonné par les normes
dissociation et la fonctionnalité de
cette dissociation entre ce que font les
conseillers économiques des ambassades
qui sont généralement chargé des grands
comptes comme on dit et puis ubifrance
qui dépend de votre ministère qui
s'occupe des pme/pmi réalisant une étude
d'impact sur l'industrie du jeu vidéo
donc j'ai procédé à des entretiens ou au
canada j'aurais pu aller finalement
directement voir les sociétés j'ai passé
par les horguais je suis passé par les
organismes officiels
alors je me retrouvais d'un côté avec
ubisoft qui est un grand compte donc été
gérée par le conseiller économique et la
myriade de pme pmi
géré par ubifrance un petit côté quand
même je ne sais pas si c'est ubuesque où
courtelinesque enfin il s'agit du même
secteur les pme pmi françaises qui vont
s'installer à montréal elles le font
aussi parce qu'il ya eu bischoff et et
c'est très compliqué parce que les
acteurs eux mêmes de notre diplomatie
économique sont très très ennuyés parce
qu'il n'y a pas de coordination
sectoriel les grands comptes d'un côté
le mae
et puis ubifrance le commerce extérieur
et c'est vrai que ça facile quand même
pas le travail de l'implantation de nos
entreprises merci merci nous par peur
protection le vendéen monsieur mercier
merci président madame le ministre juste
à souhait une interrogation à partir
d'un cas pratique
jal est sollicité par un chef
d'entreprise vendéen en relation avec
une société chinoise et qui a des
difficultés pour obtenir des services
consulaires des visas dans des délais
raisonnables pour des cadres chinois qui
viennent en formation dans l'entreprise
vendéenne
le délai est trop long et c'est un frein
supplémentaire à l'activité de cette
entreprise
il serait souhaitable qu'il y ait une
attention particulière de portée par
notre administration pour faciliter ces
échanges
merci monsieur mercier il n'y a pas que
les cadres dans les entreprises y aussi
des problèmes d'enseignants du supérieur
des recrutements on a les mêmes
problèmes
un peu partout mais nan ministre alors
il ya eu pas mal de questions sur le vin
je reconnais bien là la tradition
sénatoriales et la tradition française
que vous honorez je serai à vinexpo le
17 juin
donc j'aurais évidemment à m'exprimer à
ce sujet il est évident que je soutiens
les producteurs français et citant
monsieur karel de gucht commissaire
européen flamand avec une réputation
libéral
il a dit à ma connaissance il n'y a pas
de vins qu'ils soient subventionnées en
france pas plus qu'ailleurs bon donc
c'est quand même une grosse différence
avec les panneaux photovoltaïques
alors cela étant je voudrais quand même
vous donner des informations sur cette
affaire là la chine va faire la même
chose que fait le la commission
européenne de son côté elle va pratiquer
une enquête qui va durer et qui peut
aller jusqu'à 18 mois
elle peut prendre des mesures
provisoires de la même de la même
manière non parce que ce que vous
évoquez en disant que déjà elle bloque
des en douane des importations
ça c'était une pratique assez courante
elle n'est pas la seule à le faire c'est
vraiment tous les obstacles non
tarifaires les bisbilles elle le savez
vous qu'il y a quelques semaines j'étais
dans le cognaçais en charente
et bien pendant plusieurs semaines chine
a bloqué des balles ou de cognac
bon personne n'a su les les cognaçais
n'y tenais pas non plus à ce que ça en
face de la la publicité là dessus mais
c'est vraiment des choses qu'on voit
envoie au brésil on voit
waouh japon il ya toujours quelque chose
qui fait que donc ça de toute façon
c'est une pratique malheureusement
courante est typiquement
protectionnistes et biberons ça permet
en échange en retard bon ça fait partie
des aléas du commerce
en revanche ils le font passer pour la
première fois oui mais oui mais ça
revient un peu c'est une mesure
préventive
bon c'est pas y pratiquer à leur manière
une forme d une forme de patriotisme
mais ce que je veux dire ce qui est
important et ça c'est important pour
vous que vous le sachiez que les
défenseurs du vin là le côtes du rhône
le bordeaux le vin de l'aude bien sûr
qui est beaucoup monté en gamme en plus
bon alors oui oui mais bon en france
maintenant que le réchauffement
climatique même la reine d'angleterre
vous avez remarqué à acheter des plants
de vigne il y aura des la vigne en
angleterre alors bon donc le vin quand
même de beaux jours devant lui bon ce
que je veux dire c'est que d'une part je
pense que le haut de gamme c'est pour ça
que votre remarque sur le fil il vint
chignole machine et hr en chine comme
ailleurs il est très très très cher je
crois que tous les segments haut de
gamme
franchement même s'il ya des droits de
douane c'est hors marché voilà on est
bien d'accord et puis en revanche il n'y
a pas de moyenne gamme il ya je veux pas
être désagréable mais il ya le vin en
vrac qui est pas de levain d'une qualité
exceptionnelle et c'est vrai que là
c'est celui là qui peut qui peut
souffrir
donc je pense que il faut être attentif
alors les plaignants c'est à dire les
chinois ont fait leur propre évaluation
de ce qu'ils appellent le dumping
européen sur le vin alors ça c'est
important il estime à 21 52% alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils évoquent comme aide ça
c'est important vous le sachiez
les aides octroyées dans le cadre de
l'organisation commune de marché unique
aux cmu des plans dead
alors l'aide à la distillation par
exemple considère que ces tunnels il l'a
comptabilisent des aides à la promotion
des assurances agricoles considère de ce
sont des aides et des aides au
développement rural les aides régionales
il considère que en corse par exemple il
ya une aide régionale parce qu'il peut
pas il faut quelque part
donc voilà donc ils consolident tout ça
ils arrivent à 21,52 % faut savoir leur
méthode de comptabilité ce que nous ne
considérons pas comme des subventions
voilà mais je vous donne les chiffres
comme ça ça vous permet de vous êtes
bien placé ça vous permet de
d'argumenter alors moi je n'ai pas de
souci là dessus on est aux côtés des
producteurs je le dirai à vinexpo
publiquement mais je vous le dis d'ores
et déjà mais je pense que ça fait partie
de ceux-là
alors monsieur de montesquiou vous
parliez négocier en position c'est
justement je peux thèse me suis mal
exprimé mais jeudi à commissaire
européen
nous sommes 500 millions de
consommateurs nous sommes une force de
marcher
la première mondiale à brême le savoir
donc
servons nous de cette force de cette
attractivité pour négocier moi je ne
veux absolument pas pour se mettre en
position de faiblesse
mais dire ce qu'on veut et dire ce qu'on
ne veut pas je pense que c'est
préférable que de dire on met tout sur
la table parce que l'arrivée ça fait le
canada 5 ans après et ben on retour à la
case départ
on n'a pas avancé d'un pouce parce que
les canadiens au moment de conclure et
les négociations sont arrêtés depuis le
fin de l'année dernière le commissaire a
dit écoutez si vous remettez tout en
question faute de l'avoir réglée au
début donc je lis ne refaisons pas cette
erreur
les etats unis c
le canada puissance 10 vous l'avez dit
c'est un état fédéral bon c'est
compliqué l'inde aussi c'est très
compliqué c'est un état fédéral avec une
notion du temps qui est pas celle des
européens et des états unis où des
canadiens
donc je pense que on n'est pas en
position de faiblesse
au contraire il faut se servir de sa
force de marché qui réel pour aborder
cette négociation de manière offensive
alors monsieur bourquin a bien illustrer
le concept de réciprocité au travers des
marchés publics
comme vous le savez les marchés publics
américains sont beaucoup plus fermé que
les marchés publics européens
donc nous on veut s'appuyer tout au long
de cette négociation sur le fait que si
on ouvre il faut que l'ouverture soit en
face et après on appréciera où on met le
curseur
donc c'est pas normal que des marchés
publics soient fermés totalement et
c'est l'objet de la négociation c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de faire comprendre aux
allemands parce qu'il est que nous
sommes réciprocité ils n'aiment pas bon
et l'allemagne est une puissance
exportatrice de première heure vous avez
remarqué mais
jeu j'essaie de leur expliquer que nous
on est pour long nez pour le libre
change mais à condition que enfin sonné
la réciprocité que c'était ça la
réciprocité s'était pas d'exiger ce
qu'on ne peut pas exiger d'autres pays
mais puisqu'on ouvre il faut aussi que
les autres en face le faf
alors il a évoqué le problème de la
parité dollar dollar euro
je ferais remarquer que l'union
européenne ce ne sont pas que des pays
de la zone euro qui lie à des pays qui
n'ont pas l'euro donc le problème de la
monnaie n'est pas le sujet n'est pas le
sujet de la des négociations et je
rappelle quand même que toutes les
déclarations des g20 est récent il y en
a 1 bientôt à londres notamment par
rapport à la politique mise en oeuvre
par le premier ministre japonais
monsieur avait eu rappelle que les
délais d'évaluation de monnaies doivent
servir à relancer la demande intérieure
et pas à faire de la dévaluation
compétitive il a vu des autres économies
donc à un moment donné il faut apprécier
la portée des déclarations du g20
alors madame lamure vous avez posé un
problème
à part celui du vin comme vous êtes
rapporteur du commerce extérieur vous
avez parlé des transferts de technologie
ils sont pas dans l'accord
ça c'est une politique d'entreprise moi
je me suis exprimé exprimé là dessus et
ça ça pose le problème de ce qui est
aujourd'hui le commerce international on
n'est plus dans la notion notamment
vis-à-vis des grands émergents même des
émergents intermédiaire de on arrive
dans un pays on a le produit le meilleur
en levant soit on a un produit de niche
effectivement là il n'y a pas de sujet
soit on est en concurrence ce qui nous
arrive quand même assez souvent compris
avec nos amis allemands ou espagnols ou
italiens
quand même sur beaucoup de de marché et
c'est vrai que tous ces pays vous
demande de vous internationalisé
ça veut dire y'a un ticket d'entrée sur
un marché il faut produire localement et
en général les entreprises elles font
leurs arbitrages elles produisent là où
sont leurs marchés parce que on est
toujours mieux proche de son marché et
en même temps c'est vrai que ils
demandent des transferts de compétences
des transferts de savoir faire et des
transferts de technologie et dans le
commerce aujourd'hui tel qu'il est
internationalisé il faut prendre c'est
tous ces facteurs et admettre qu'un
qu'un comment dire qu'un acheteur de nos
produits et nos services soient aussi un
partenaire
d'où la nécessité pour de nombreuses
entreprises de trouver des partenaires
les gens il veut faire des gens aventure
faire de la croissance externe racheter
des entreprises
mais en même temps de transférer une
partie de leurs compétences à leur faut
que dans certains secteurs stratégiques
le nucléaire par exemple ce est évident
que l'état c'est un secteur stratégique
l'état a son mot à dire et il le dit ne
serait ce que parce qu'il participe aux
conseils d'administration des deux
grandes sociétés donc il doit encadrer
ces transferts mais il faut admettre que
celui qui aujourd'hui
un acheteur devient un partenaire est de
plus en plus c'est ça c'est du
partenariat industriel et peut-être
demain un concurrent tout le savoir donc
il faut toujours avoir un point d'avancé
de valeur ajoutée sur notre territoire
c'est pour ça que nous avons une grande
attractivité notamment au travers de
deux du crédit impôt-recherche faut pas
le nier c'est important mais aussi au
travers du crédit impôt de compétitivité
et je pense qu'il faut toujours garder
ce temps d'avant ce parce que il ya des
pays qui nous rattrape assez vite
enfin il ya de la marge encore faut pas
se faire peur alors vous allez poser la
question des chiffres du commerce
extérieur vous avez bien lu les chiffres
madame la rapporteure c'est vrai qu'en
2012 on est passé de 74 milliards de
déficit la 67 milliards que nous avons
une facture énergétique a augmenté aussi
bon moi j'ai reçu un objectif c'est
d'arriver à l'équilibré hors énergie
parce que l'énergie franchement cours du
pétrole je sais pas faire je sais faire
de l'efficacité énergétique et en plus
je sais la vendre dans le monde parce
que tous les pays même ceux qui sont des
gros fournisseurs de pétrole se
préoccupent d'efficacité énergétique
j'ai pu le constater dans toute la
péninsule arabique
la preuve même les l'arabie saoudite est
en train de travailler avec la france
pour se doter d'une industrie nucléaire
ces lointains mais ça avance donc je
vois bien que tout le monde est soucieux
de de ne pas dilapider sa ressource
pétrolière et gazière
donc les chiffres sont en légère
amélioration une hirondelle ne fait pas
le printemps le premier trimestre vous
avez vous avez raison si je compare au
premier trimestre de l'année dernière il
n'est pas bon le mois de mars a permis
n'a pas peur a été meilleure mais n'a
pas permis de rattraper alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est sur notre marché de
proximité
on a un problème marché proximité c'est
l'europe
et on a un problème par exemple on le
voit très bien dans l'automobile c'est
la chute de l'espagne et de l'italie qui
franchement là nous plombe
alors il ya en avril les chiffres
d'avril sont meilleurs mais ils sont
même assez bon il ya un rebond de nos
exportations
non je crois qu'on fait un saut de 4 et
quelques pour cent mais de nos
importations aussi mais ce qui n'est pas
forcément mauvais ça veut dire que
peut-être que on pourrait faire repartir
un peu de croissance
et c'est vrai que ce que donne la
commission européenne les deux ans
d'ajustement budgétaire c'est quand même
bienvenu en france et c'est une
bienvenue immédiat pour l'italie pour
l'espagne cela étant quand les
l'automobile repart les importations
surtout repartent donc on sait bien que
on a un problème concurrentiel
donc on le sait ça je vois que de plus
en plus beaux jo est en train de de de
se développer hors d'europe
je les ai rencontrés la semaine dernière
en asie du sud est et je leur ai dit
vous avez beaucoup de
dans tous ces pays où vous devriez
vraiment faire des scooters parce que
tout le monde ne peut pas se payer une
voiture en asie du sud est et c'est très
prisé donc ils vont essayer de voir mais
je pense qu'ils font une usine ou
vietnam s'ils le font parce qu'ils
veulent être prêts de leur marché ça ça
me paraît une stratégie d'entreprise
normal alors vous avez évoqué monsieur
vaugrenard
à juste titre et ça a été aussi évoquée
par monsieur gataullin je crois mais le
rapprochement vous avez pas être parti
de des normes sociales et c'est vrai ça
me permet de répondre aussi à ce
monsieur bizet sur ce point vous avez
parlé du commerce mondial des règles de
l'om c'est moi j'ai reçu vous avez parlé
de la nomination du nouveau directeur
général il se trouve que c'est monsieur
azevedo de nationalité brésilienne j'ai
reçu les neuf c'est ma compétence
j'ai reçu les neuf candidats un parent
quelques fois deux fois et j'ai posé à
tous la même question et dans les
questions que j'ai posées il y en avait
une c'est le fait que l' omc doit se
rapprocher des autres organisations
internationales notamment celles de
l'oit et alors c'est des domaines
différents
mais on ne peut pas s'extraire de cela
parce qu'on sait bien que c'est une
source de concurrence déloyale
hormis le problème des droits de l'homme
du respect des droits des enfants etc
il ya des problème tout bête qui sont de
nature de déséquilibres commerciaux et
économiques
donc je pense que l'om c'est celle à
revendre bin c'est là ce que j'ai
demandé à celui qui est gelée revue
monsieur azevedo je lui ai dit la même
chose il faut aussi regarder au delà et
vous remercie monsieur bizet d'avoir
rendu hommage à pascal lamy qui a été
dans des circonstances difficiles c'est
quand même la crise européenne et la
crise mondiale
et finalement quand on regarde il a bien
contenu les réflexes protectionnistes
il a bien fait marcher le rd l'organisme
de règlement des différends commerciaux
quand je vois le dynamisme des et des
enquêtes en 2012
je pense que il a tenu bon sur les
grands principes du libre échange et
mais en même temps du respect des règles
de l'om c'est avec des nouveaux
partenaires et puis
vous avez vu les chiffres le commerce
mondial maintenant c'est un tiers sud
sud
ce n'est plus ce qu'ils étaient il ya
dix ans un tiers sud sud ça veut dire
que beaucoup de pays en voie de
développement
sans rentrer dans le monde du commerce
alors je continue avec vous monsieur
bizet vous avez posé une question fort
juste les grands émergents et les autres
parce qu'il y en a quand même
quelques-uns
et puis le bilatéralisme le
multilatéralisme
moi je crois que ce qui a fait exploser
les règles habituelles puisque le
multilatéral il est en panne lorna une
échéance importante qui notamment sur la
facilitation du commerce à bali au mois
de décembre la 9e conférence
ministérielle ou là le nouveau directeur
va être en prise avec la facilitation du
commerce
là on va voir si on relance un peu ce
cycle de doha mais c'est vrai qu'il est
encalminée et pourquoi les grands
émergents ont fait exploser les règles
habituelles du commerce mondial parce
que ils sont devenus des puissances
commerciales
je pense au brésil à la chine moindre
mesure la russie mais quand même ils
sont devenus des puissances commerciales
de premier ordre et en même temps ils
n'assument pas leurs responsabilités de
puissance commerciale
quand on devient une puissance on a des
responsabilités vis-à-vis du reste du
monde et c'est ça qui crée la distorsion
c'est pour ça que je reviens aux accords
de libre-échange tels que le trans
partenaires passé le trans pacific
partnership et avec les états unis et
auquel le japon veut se rallier pas
neutre au japon il négocie à la fin avec
l'union européenne et avec les
américains et puis l'accord de
libre-échange yeux
états unis je crois que là les grands
émergents ce sont quelque part mis au
pied du mur par ces négociations parce
que il faut qu'ils assument leurs
responsabilités alors si on voit bien je
prends le brésil je le stigmatise pas
mettant tous est un pays riche avec des
pauvres tantôt c'est un pays pauvre avec
des riches
bon voila voila pour l'audition de
nicole bricq la ministre du commerce
extérieur si vous souhaitez à la revoir
elle est disponible en vod sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr à suivre
l'émission politique de la rédaction de
public sénat preuve par 3 bonne soirée à
tous